[Música]
buenos días niños porque llegaron tarde
y se quedaron jugando en la calle yo les
dije que en la calle no se juega no me
hacen caso juanito te vi caminando por
la calle no por la acera cuando venías
en la mañana para la escuela no me
seguís haciendo caso
como que no hay aceras que no hay aceras
vamos a tener que hablar con la
municipalidad entonces tendrán que pasar
por el paso peatonal o por las líneas
cebras que no hay líneas cebras y
tampoco espacio peatonal
bueno bueno bueno tendrán que jugar en
el parque no maría no me contradiga como
que no hay parques claro si lo vi lleno
de basura ya no hay niños en el la
verdad tener razón y yo no he ido al
parque bueno después hablaremos de estos
temas ahora pongan atención como todos
los días mucha atención no se vayan a
ensuciar no corran no se rían cuidado se
van a mojar los pies con el agua de la
lluvia ahí creo que me faltaba alguno
más pero no lo recuerdo
bueno perdón perdón camila que decís no
te escucho como que yo digo mucho no
pero si se me olvidaron algunos nuevos
que que que la escuela debe debe igual
que la ciudad prohibir menos y saludar
más
camila yo no sé hacer eso cómo se hace
eso que pongamos rótulos por la ciudad
que digan buenos días que le vaya bien
en el brete y cuando venga del brete por
el otro lado diga cómo le fue
saludos a la familia no se olvide llevar
el pancito
y que también cuando es el día del niño
llenen de rótulos de niños la ciudad se
vería feliz llena de colores y que
también pongan poemas conoceríamos a los
poetas de la ciudad
camila qué buena idea no se me hubiese
ocurrido jamás hacer eso
blues y tener la mano levantada vos
querés opinar adelante
[Música]
como por ejemplo la seguridad a veces
queremos ir a la casa de nuestros
abuelos pero no podemos porque nuestros
papás no lo dejan porque es muy seguro
por más cerca que vivan es muy peligroso
digo no y también es muy importante que
los niños los pregunte nietos que
quieren en la ciudad porque los niños
están en la ciudad y tienen derecho a
escoger qué quieren ellos pueden tener
diferentes gustos con los adultos
entonces es siempre se ha dicho que las
cosas de los niños van a ser para el
futuro pero muchos niños ya esperan 2 un
juego nuevos y todo pero a veces no les
preguntan que a los niños nos gusta que
me pregunten que quieren porque ellos
quieren hacer una ciudad mejor
a lo que camina y lucía nos piden es un
cambio pues vamos a cambiar vamos a
hacer hoy la clase un poco diferente
vamos a hablar de la ciudad y eso me
recuerda me recuerda la frase de mi
amigo antonio manríquez arquitecto
colombiano cuando decía un muro separa
una ventana comunica y un parque integra
no ocuparemos muros hoy no ocuparemos
muros abriremos todas las ventanas y
haremos de esta gran aula un gran parque
una gran ciudad una gran tienda de
campaña
voy a hacer hoy la profe arquitecta que
le pregunta a todos los niños las ideas
de su ciudad y lo haremos a través del
arte el juego y la diversión
no lo haremos a través del arte el juego
y la diversión porque experimentaremos
lo lindo que es como experiencia humana
vivir en comunidad
desarrollaremos un mundo de sensaciones
de sensaciones y emociones a través de
la ciudad y de la arquitectura
hoy desarrollaremos el sentido de
pertenencia de apropiación entenderemos
cómo se vive la ciudad la observaremos
la viviremos la experimentaremos la
caminaremos la lloraremos y la vamos a
abrazar desarrollaremos una ciudad
humana y desarrollaremos una cultura
urbana una cultura ciudadana no es más
que una educación para la vida
pero como lo hacemos primero primero que
nada tenemos que saber dónde vivimos
donde nos ubicamos donde estamos nuestra
ciudad un mapa es una buena idea para
iniciar y también tenemos que tener
ideas para la ciudad como todos ustedes
la tienen seguramente nunca les han
preguntado cómo es la ciudad como la
quieren pues hoy lo vamos a hacer
feve sede contame qué querés de tu
ciudad que quieres sombrillas para el
parque y para qué querés sombrillas para
el parque para que la lluvia no te pare
la diversión qué manera tan poética de
pedir los techos para el parque
hoy debemos participar activamente niños
jóvenes y adultos tenemos el derecho de
participar activamente tenemos que tener
un lugar un lugar de opinión de la
ciudad y la escuela es el perfecto lugar
los niños tienen derecho a proponer a
proponer y a ser escuchado
roberto roberto contanos vos esta idea
decime vos querés caminar con tu abuelo
de la mano claro hay que darle un
espacio y tiempo a los abuelos cuantas
historias nos cuentan los abuelos se han
fijado como vivíamos antes como
jugábamos como nos juntábamos en familia
a departir como nos sentábamos en ese
corredor a conversar como nos íbamos al
patio nos subíamos al palo de guayaba a
sacar guayabas
esa historia esas raíces es lo que somos
ahora el patrimonio el patrimonio
también es ciudad al en esta oportunidad
para decirnos por qué no te gusta ir a
san jose h&p como le decimos de cariño
no te gusta como puede ser a mí tampoco
me gustaría claro porque las carteras y
los bolsos de los mandados te pegan en
la cabeza nos hemos olvidado de las
proporciones de las medidas la ciudad
necesita de las matemáticas si miran al
alrededor todos somos diferentes y
medimos diferentes tenemos antropometría
la medida de nuestro cuerpo y la ciudad
no está siendo inclusiva hay lugares que
son inaccesibles para unos que tienen
movilidad es diferentes debemos pensar
en la ciudad en una ciudad donde cabemos
todos para todos gran desafío
hoy todos quisieron dar ideas ignacio
contanos porque dibujaste esos garabatos
perdón perdón no son garabatos disculpen
mi manera disculpa gimnasio mi manera
adulta de leer tu dibujo por supuesto si
está clarísimo es un montón de basura
que no ha sido separada y no ha sido
reciclada y vos querés ayudar al
ambiente clarísimo julia contanos el
dibujo tuyo que está la parte de ignacio
vos querés un museo en el barrio porque
porque tus vecinos son artistas si
quieres exponer las obras de arte y
quieres contar toda la historia de tu
barrio porque sé cómo ha ido
evolucionando y vos querés clases de
teatro de danza y de pintura soy una
artista julia sos un artista
[Música]
con tantas ideas tan diversas que
tenemos tenemos que contarlas hay que
contar la voz de los niños a todo el
mundo a todos los encargados de
construir y diseñar nuestras ciudades
pero cómo lo hacemos y cómo lo hacemos
alguno tiene una idea no se me ocurre
qué decides andrés con un juego
diseñamos un juego y unamos todas las
ideas como llamarías el juego juego cubo
ideas claro todas las ideas juntas y
sería una gran ciudad que se puede
seguir creciendo conforme preguntemos a
todos los niños del mundo
pero por qué decís que es un cubo de 5
lados
la semana pasada estudiamos el juego y
vimos que tiene 6 caras
perdón otra vez mi forma adulta de leer
un juego claro si ponemos la sexta idea
y la apoyamos es una idea excluida no se
lee ellos siempre pensando en el grupo
en el equipo en los amigos cuánto
tenemos que aprender en los adultos eso
somos adultos diseñando y construyendo
para los niños y pocas veces le
preguntamos cómo quieren sus espacios su
cuarto su área de juego su ciudad su
aula su patio escolar nos
sorprenderíamos de lo que nos dice
y también quisieron participar los de
preescolar ellos en el curso de teatro y
de artes plásticas la pasaron muy bien
hicieron una alegría para el patio
escolar que denominaron la alegría en
una escultura porque la pasaron muy bien
les quedó chiquis y más chicos
en las ciudades las podemos ver de
muchos ángulos en este caso los niños
escogieron el ángulo de mondrian
estudiamos a mondrian estudiamos su
estilo hicimos los mobiliarios los
edificios estudiamos toda la ciudad pero
sobre todo hicimos lo más importante que
es lo más importante de las ciudades eso
sofía las personas las ciudades son para
nosotros para las personas las personas
somos los únicos que podemos abrazar la
ciudad eso me recuerda lo que nos
dijeron unos amigos del rosario
argentina de la muni cuando decían la
ciudad es un texto poderoso para crear y
abrazar la vida nosotros tenemos que
abrazar la vida a través de la escuela
de la ciudad de la casa
tenemos la responsabilidad como
ciudadanos y profesionales de proponer
un cambio en los procesos educativos a
través de diferentes formas de aprender
a través del juego lúdico de la
participación de la integración del
juego libre si realmente queremos
cambiar ciudades y ciudadanos desde
tempranas edades
y tenemos que hacerlo juntos
multidisciplinariamente desde la escuela
a la casa el barrio todos juntos e
incluir estas ideas de los niños
analizarlas procesarlas y por qué no
aplicarlas en definitiva lo que los
niños y jóvenes quieren es una ciudad
humana como los letreros de camila una
ciudad
cercana como caminar con el abuelo de la
mano de roberto una ciudad amiga como
cuando ya no nos golpean en las carteras
por la cabeza es una ciudad que
definitivamente tiene que aún
emocionarnos y sorprendernos fuertemente
por las cosas más pequeñas como poner
una flor abrazar un gran árbol tomarse
un buen café conversado con los amigos
ir a leer un buen libro en un parque con
las sombrillas de fede por si acaso
llueve
necesitamos espacios de encuentro en
nuestras ciudades como este si realmente
queremos una ciudad con calidad de vida
óptima debemos verla llena de niños
corriendo por todas partes eso lo dice
yang el gran organista dan esto y lo
reafirma francesco tonucci sigo pedagogo
y dibujante italiano cuando nos dice si
la ciudad es segura para los niños lo
será para el resto de sus ciudadanos hay
que devolverle a la ciudad de los niños
y la autonomía algo muy importante de
hacer pero para eso tenemos que querer y
tenemos que hacer y tenemos que hacerlo
ya y ahora que ya va terminando esta
clase
yo me voy a poner y llevarme puesta
todas las ideas de los niños de todos
ustedes y vamos a ir al recreo que es lo
que todo nos gusta pero antes de ir al
recreo tengo que dejarles la tarea de
todos los días
apunten la hagan la bien y tráiganme la
lo mejor que puedan hecha la tarea es
jugar jugar y jugar porque jugar también
es ciudad
[Aplausos]
[Música]